hey Dan I heard you just went to check
out sunset overdrive I did what'd ya
think of it uh it was pretty cool yeah I
spoke to one of the days as well Marcus
Smith and um he said something really
interesting he was like it's kind of
inspired by pinball I never really
picked up on that it's a game where the
gameplay is based on momentum it was
inspired a lot by drew Murray the game
director I'm creative director he's game
director we we came up with this baby
together in a romantic way and and the
idea that he had always had was games
you know pinball games was a good
example in like the game monster bash
and in particular it was you would build
up by like unlocking this part and then
this partner this part in a minute we're
all crazy and so we were saying early on
we wanted to build it on momentum and so
now you start off and as you got to
start getting into fights you're
building up your style meter your
unlocking amps amps are getting more
crazy or building up with shyla meter
even bigger now you've just got like
explosions going off everywhere chaos
happening but it's things that were a
result of you your input and therefore
it felt rewarding you know it wasn't so
much just random stuff going on it was a
lot more like you did something awesome
it feels great it's it's sort of a
philosophy that they're extending to the
accessibility as well where they're like
we want you to be able to jump in and
start easily but once things start
getting crazy that's where the skill
kicks in and so when they continue with
their completely ridiculous theme
they're very self referential and I
break the fourth wall a lot as well I
love a lot of games that take themselves
very seriously like I don't I don't want
to pick on Last of Us I love last of us
it's a great great game but we're kind
of the opposite of last of us and I feel
like in a lot of cases there's games
that have tried to eliminate HUD and do
all these things and you know HUD is how
you know a lot of information so by
removing it there's that ambiguity and
for us we embrace there's a HUD and we
call it out a lot of times and we remind
the player the player reminds the player
character will remind the player
occasionally about things that are very
gaming I mean it's an open world game
and we have fast travel and how
we have fast travel player will remind
you everyone smile like that's really
far good thing there's fast travel the
character is sort of like referencing
the fact that he's in a video game and
and it's the kind of thing that last
boss would never actually do what's
interesting you say that I mean like
we've seen a lot of footage from the
game so far I'm actually curious to know
like where the story will go once the
games almost reached its end point right
well I mean like there's this whole sort
of idea that you're fighting off an
infection people who are infected with
an energy drink and he was sort of
hinting at the fact that something is
going to happen within the world that is
going to change it structurally we tried
very hard not to eliminate traversal
elements completely so a lot of cases
you know things will the cars will
explode but they're still bouncing ball
we have sections of the map that that
change I won't give away a pivotal story
moment but there is there's something
that happens where there's part of the
environment that wasn't there before but
that's all fully traversable so when you
when you even actually finished the the
story mode you can go back and now
that's a part of the world that you can
traverse in and again it's just that
that constant this is a game where
designers and environment artist had to
be in lockstep because you interact with
the environment so it's not so much you
know a lot of games you build a world
and then you allow the environment
artists to just make it look good and
make it feel lived in and in this case
they had to do all that but also had to
fit the traversal metrics so this needs
to be eight meters long I don't you know
figure out how to make that look good so
and that is because the player needs it
to be that long to know that they can
land on it grind on it and get off in
time